spiders
put that script down now
put the jokes down
hands over the head turn around
Crowder do you want to get demonetized
pay attention get down on your knees
right now
whatever
what happened where'd he go God did an
Amy Schumer I feel pretty right off this
Dam right here really yeah boom
foreign
[Music]
New York Mets this summer and they have
a guy in the booth he's going to donate
a thousand dollars to a children's
cancer hospital every time one of the
Mets hits a home run cheap
you know what I could I'll do it my
Shelby mug club now
[Applause]
be more proof Hitler killed all the
funny Jews
I got this girl back to my apartment she
took her bra off one of her nipples was
offset by like two inches so I said
where'd you get Marshalls Andy Dick pick
a hole and stick with it got a kid from
the Make-A-Wish Foundation Billy what's
your last wish I don't know can we get a
designated hitter in the National League
don't build another Ronald McDonald
House move the fences in a city field
but say look at me
Stevie Van Zandt issued a call to
exterminate that's Holocaust speak by
the way
exterminate the Republican cockroaches
to that I say
here you go Stevie hope that's not too
strong for the first half of the show
[Music]
[Applause]
oh that is delicious it is hot I still
don't get I don't know I don't know how
to gauge the heat of the drink before I
go live on air you could take a sip
before you go live it would seem like
that's a simple solution but I like to
complicate things needlessly
uh so glad to be with you today I know
yesterday we did uh we did a little bit
of a little bit of a took a flyer right
with the uh the the uh the untold
history uh Muhammad Ali I hope you enjoy
it go and watch that but today we have a
lot to talk about Dalai Lama's a pervert
surprise the leader of an
inconsequential religion and I know some
of you saying that's offensive what I
mean to say by inconsequential don't
misunderstand me is that Tibetan
Buddhism doesn't matter uh Elon Musk
destroyed stuck The Landing hey reporter
at the BBC uh with some leading
questioning and I think it's actually a
master class and how to handle uh biased
journalists you know I came under the
two came up under the tutelage of Andrew
Breitbart and we'll show you some clips
there and actually how to deal with
people like this in your own life and
Gavin Newsom
a little bit uh he is doing a tour of
red States right now and you may have
heard of this uh here's the thing he's
going around with talking points that
are all verifiably false now I don't
think some of the all all are verifiably
false and we will arm you with that
information figuratively so that when
you hear people say this in comparing
California to Florida you are you are
good to go and yep Nick depalo by the
way you can go to lotto's creditor.com
mug club we now have his show 5 p.m at
night four times a week yeah so you get
this show it's a live show Monday
through Monday through Thursday five no
hold on a second Monday through Thursday
10 a.m is this show so just bookmark it
right tune in it's a live show and of
course Friday on Mud Club it's also live
so it's every day 10 AM if you're on mug
club or on rumble of course uh it's uh
Monday through Thursday and then Nick
depalo four times a week at five boom so
you've got five times a week this Nick
depaolo and of course we have other
comedy specials other series coming in
but let's introduce everyone who is here
uh are you okay there pops cried are you
on your phone no something more
important I would not be on my phone
good Lord that's Brian oh so you're just
playing with yourself Gerald hey CEO how
are you sir I am doing well how are you
good busy 24 hours very busy yeah so I'm
glad it's a fun show it's going to be a
really fun show we're dealing with
perverts and oh well and perverts so we
have the Dalai Lama and Gavin Newsom
yeah get my hand down but but one
African-American Elon Musk that'll be
fun there you go yeah now uh in third
chair today we have both pops Crowder
and uh Brian Callan who by the way will
be in Portland April 20th through the
22nd and you can see the rest of his
dates there at briancallen.com go check
out US tour Brian Cowan how are you sir
I'm just a man I never know if I should
have my arms up here because this way
you see more of my traps right yeah and
my neck gets a little it fans out a
little bit so I look like I'm ready yes
because you got to be ready nowadays huh
guys yeah because the Liberals are on
the march with the black shirt there out
of my eye I thought Lee Haney and I was
like it's just Brian Carey
and uh pops Crowder who feels great
shame but uh that's right I'm sitting
here with a Pro and what am I doing one
of these things is not like well people
like you yeah comment below guys you
like pops Crowder there on the show
don't stir them he's gonna he's gonna
take my comedy Workshop guys that's
right a lot of Hands-On a lot of
Hands-On relaxation work a lot of
Puppets
my question for you uh question uh for
the day here what was your biggest uh I
think it's a hand saw bone sauce too
small you can't play the bonesaw say
bone again stop it sorry I'm 10. they
speak English in Bones so what was your
main takeaway from the Muhammad Ali
documentary yesterday Cassius Clay
Muhammad Ali again a lot of history if
you didn't watch it spoiler alert
campaign for Oren hatch and was buddies
with Donald Trump and supported him so a
lot of people don't know that the media
tries to hide that from you go and watch
the full documentary but before we get
to that here's a uh broad
um oh
okay everything now is ugly and we're
supposed to celebrate it and I know what
you're saying well beauty is in the eye
of the beholder sure I get that some
people like big women some people like
small women
um and yes we are the byproduct of our
times
but hairy armpits are a hard pass no
matter how hard you try and sell them
I'm on a journey of growing out my
armpit hair for the first time as a
woman and you know what I realized
yesterday when talking to a guy Amazing
Ideas are quality detectors if a man
said immediately no to me dismiss me
simply because of the fact that I have
hair growing out of this yeah
that says the most keep the walking
button if the guy realized that in fact
it's the same hair that he has it's just
hair or in fact he liked them keep
walking the guy would be able to break
the Combine 40 record for crying out
what you guys are too conservative I
don't mind hair under a woman's arms I
just don't like hair on a woman's balls
yes
that's where I draw the lineup I hate to
be that concerned I'm old-fashioned no I
know I know you're old-fashioned and a
lot of and here's how I know that you're
open-minded a lot of traditional you
know patriarchists would draw the line
at balls which I think is wrong right I
think it's no serious I mean I don't
know why you would discriminate in that
way you shouldn't no it's I mean some
women the balls have a attack okay
come on all right see we're gonna get
Fly and by the way I think they always
do okay I don't know that they come
without one okay so you're a
traditionalist not Joe Lewis might you
know beg ziffer have we hit the YouTube
dump button oh yeah by the way before I
move on here if you see this at any
point if you are watching on YouTube
all right that means just head on over
to rumble which we want you to do anyway
because we've been uh struck twice on
YouTube technically three but really
only two times so anyway back to Harry
armpit broad
um this by the way is a trend now it
reminds me of you guys have all seen the
Amazon commercial with the lady with the
mustache
um I've been seeing this a lot lately
and I don't really get many commercials
but now I'm not willing to pay for a
premium peacock I was watching The
Undertaker documentary and you're done
so I no yeah I'm done with it but I
still have the commercial so this
commercial has been popping up in my
feed a lot of people saying that a woman
with a mustache is you know woke but
here's the thing the commercial people
think it's for Amazon there's more
context and we always believe that you
should have that so this is the full
mustache girl commercial
[Music]
destinations
come on I just saw the shortened version
I never saw it yeah it's a tourism
change one thing put some Weird Al
Yankovic musical yeah and then you've
got a product and she was so close by
the way to uh just Amazon priming razors
but instead she decided that she wanted
to go the Michael Jackson Thriller
jacket in the Lionel Richie hairdo like
yeah no that's not more work just
this there's a sequel commercial about
it she looked more like a Weird Al is
that a real commercial yeah
Nothing's Gonna distract from that yeah
by the way and here's the thing the
reason that Michael Jackson and I get it
that he's a Serial pedophile rapist but
here's the point
he could get away with looking like that
in that mustache because of undeniably
immense Talent you're just a girl with a
mustache shave it and move on with your
life from the island of Life yes the
Island of Lesbos where they all come
from yeah we always think the Island of
Lesbos looks like we're like oh I don't
live less but it's like a fantasy but
really it's just a bunch of chicks who
buy their plaid shirts at Orvis oh to be
fair that music in the background was
kazakhstani well I guess I don't know
something Caucasus Mountains in the
comment section thank you for the caucus
mountains thank you for your job well
you know what's funny is actually they
have a whole argument about Greek coffee
or Turkish coffee or middle eastern
coffee it's all the same exact thing
yeah they all claim it so yeah here's
our coffee this is why I can't be
president if I had the red button this
is like well it's Greek coffee it's
Turkish
same thing pipe down in there you make
me tired you go retire at 43 dummies all
right speaking of dummies Dalai Lama
okay I know some of you like them and by
some of you I mean if you're stupid now
during an M3 and I mean this it's silly
it's dumb I'm sorry the Dalai Lama is
inconsequential it's a religion that's
just your own personal happiness is what
matters they've never really contributed
anything to the modern world societies
based around this whether it's Tibetan
moodism whether it's there's uh Buddhism
there's Hinduism which is kind of what
it branches they're all different kinds
of Buddhism so I understand it don't
correct me on which kind of Buddhism I'm
talking about here I get it the point is
the Dalai Lama sucks and I'm pretty sure
he's a pedophile here's why during the
m3m foundation event that took place
last month it's been making the runs
Dalai Lama told a young boy and I know
what you're thinking cultural
differences
I'm not sure which culture has you
request that a young boy suck your
tongue and you're not a pedophile but
here's your proof
[Music]
[Laughter]
thank you yeah thank you
yeah the thing about Enlightenment the
Dalai Lama said is that it's in his ass
well it was just the tip yeah I think
that's that's your son do you know are
you not are you not just punching the
dollar receives Enlightenment on his
deathbed then that's all that kind what
should be nice matters but if it's your
son and it's let's someone asked your
son to suck his tongue how fast before
they have to pry you off it's the only
time I would throw the Dalai Lama in a
flying headlock yes that's where I think
it'd be I think it's time for him to
light himself on fire in protest he
needs the people's elbow now a CNN
panelist
defended the spiritual leader I use that
term loosely I don't know about you I
don't know how easy it would to follow
Jesus Christ if he had a 250 000 wrist
watch but
tomato fraud so
they defended the Dalai Lama of course
as being playful and playful
Jay you've met the Dalai Lama many times
have you such a song I have not uh
yeah he has a full human being and we
may see this in a weird kind of gross
sexualized yeah yeah
sexual as a bowl of plain rice there is
sticky rice sexual erotic or erotic
happening in this encounter oh yeah no
we have some uh sticky fried yeah
I mean talk about spreading covet guys
yes exactly no that's not safe she's a
super spreader you know what I'm saying
that's how monkeypox got started yeah
but your tongue's not dirty no well
that's how they told me I'd become a
deity yeah exactly Steven Seagal
remembers wisdom said I was the
reincarnate of the some kind of it's a
good it's a good commercial for our
tongue scrape yes you know what I mean
keep your tongue clean enough to suck on
it's a good for a stranger to sucker oh
you'll tastes good at six year old
Listerine can your kids suck my tongue
oh gosh this is just again people Dustin
Hoffman got me too for telling dirty
jokes on set 40 years ago this guy's
having minors suck his tongue and you're
running interference and they're looking
for every single reason they can find to
criticize Christians and even criticize
Jesus and at some point trying memoryol
as though it was a historical figure
even though you've done that in the
apologetic segment on Friday every
single major historian agrees that the
point is it's silly I'm sorry anyone
who's into the Eastern religion
mysticism you are lost the Dalai Obama
is a lost soul and you can comment below
if you find that offensive I don't
really care CNN was not the only one
with an opinion however uh uh most happy
uh regarding this news and supportive
was this guy
swing yeah
not all Catholics just the Pope
but the pope knows nothing about your
root chakra yes exactly I don't even
know that you know what it's one of
those things that means nothing what do
you mean it's down here it starts here
does it start yes and ends with your
tongue oh
well you learned something new every day
but I don't like it so
the Dalai Lama is a fraud by the way he
gave uh he yeah he did he declared
Steven Seagal uh to be some kind of
Incarnate of some kind of God because
Steven Seagal gave a bunch of money to
some Temple right when people
about Joel Osteen putting money in walls
for some reason they give a pass to the
guy who literally said oh you'll give
money Stephen so go no problem you can't
fight and movie fraud I will call you
God you are now God King he also has a
watch collection by the way including
like two Rolexes so this is about fine I
guess yes it's got nicer watches than
that right yeah sure yeah you find you
find Enlightenment at the Omega store
oh my gosh that's just that last plane
of in Hollywood how many people tell you
right Brian like yeah I practice a
tantric uh meditation meditation is how
you kind of you you become a witness to
everything going on around you right and
you practice Detachment right and that's
important because if you do it enough
then you end up not caring about your
own children exactly yeah they're less
of a distraction you yes right you're
detached as hell that's right you are
completely absent father it's about
doing what I want for myself
it's like countries you're measuring by
their contribution that's true it's good
it was a good point earlier you're
saying Tibet uh Tibet uh not a hotbed
for technological advancements no human
rights they have a high map or freeing
people yeah well Brad Pitt spent seven
years there oh good can you go back I
want seven years of my ass
[Laughter]
why are you turning right into a power
ful no no he's in he's in he's in the
he's in the Dalai Lama oh okay
make good feeling is that's fine
Enlightenment back there up there
that seems like a super Chinese accent
not a Tibetan accent well you know what
I don't necessarily understand the
schisms okay
it's regional yeah why don't you do why
don't you do Catholic in uh in the
Eastern Orthodox church next
which by the way is a whole topic that's
just kind of funny when you look at the
difference that's a Christian
intersectionalist joke yes yes yeah so
I'm a fan these are Orthodox not big
fans of the uh the pope either too so
here's something while we're talking
about being observant being enlightened
being um detached I do like that Elon
Musk is detached from the Hollywood uh
Elite the media Elite this is the
problem with a lot of people in big Tech
I don't know if you follow this story
but I've talked about the big Tech right
entertainment media industrial complex
because people throw that out with the
military industrial complex they are one
and the same and so often the
zuckerbergs uh so often the the Jack
dorseys the Susan wojcicki's the mohans
right they want they desperately want to
be a part of the cool kids club and
that's why it's this sort of incestuous
relationship with journalists Elon Musk
is similar to Trump in this way and he's
not perfect there have been issues with
Twitter believe me that's not lost on me
but the spirit of him clearly reviling
those in the media and understanding the
tactics that they will use is of value
the last person who I witnessed who did
it this well was Andrew Breitbart that's
the man on the wall right there he's
the first person to have ever taken any
of my I met him because he took one of
my old stand-up videos and posted it
back on big Hollywood before it was
Breitbart anything it was just big
hollywood.breitepart.com and we became
good friends uh he understood the media
because he was raised in in Brentwood in
Hollywood and he understood how to fight
back Elon Musk does a pretty close job I
want you to watch this and there are a
lot of lessons that you can take with it
here he is with a BBC reporter live
interview or Wednesday right so this was
yes Tuesday night yeah yeah so you think
if something is slightly sexist it
should be bent
I'm asking for specific examples
um and if and you just said that if
something is slightly sexist that's
hateful content does that mean that it
should be bad well you've asked me
you've asked me whether my feed whether
it's got less or more I'd say it's got
slightly more that's why I'm asking for
example remember he said that right can
you name one example I I honestly don't
need honestly I can't name a single
example
feed anymore because I just don't
particularly like it a lot of people a
lot of people are quite similar I I I
don't let them out don't give them me
out Elon doesn't see more hateful
content but you can't name a single
example not even one I'm not sure I've
used that fee for the last
three or four weeks and then how did you
see the headboard content because I've
been I've been using it I've been using
twister since you've taken over for the
last six months okay so then you must
have at some point seen that you've
poured you hateful content I'm asking
for one example right and you can't give
us something and I'm saying I I say so
that you don't know what you're talking
about
a single example of hateful content not
even one tweet and yet you're claimed
that the hateful content was high well
that's a pulse no what I create a slide
what no no what I claim was uh there are
many uh organizations that say that that
kind of information is on other
organizations right whether it has
examples I mean right he's not letting
him go this is important strategic
dialogue Institute in the U in the UK
they will say that so people will say
all sorts of nonsense I'm literally
asking for a single example and you
can't name one right and as I've already
said I don't use that feed but how would
you know that I don't think this is
getting anything you literally said you
expect it's not getting anywhere this is
what happens with narcissists and
sociopath it's not getting anywhere
because they are lying it's not getting
anywhere because you're lying it would
get exactly where this interview should
go if you weren't lying couple things
that he did there and I'll show you a
clip of Andrew Breitbart right away when
he knew it was an unfair and loaded
question he pointed it out and asked him
why he was asking that question he
defined the terms why are you using that
term this is why this is good if someone
is trying to argue in good faith you can
use a Socratic method and say well on a
second what do you mean by yeah you know
slightly sexist content now if someone
is arguing in good faith and you can see
this and change my mind they'll go well
what I mean is maybe things that might
be denigrating women maybe things that
might be perpetual and perpetuating
stereotypes and then if you don't have a
satisfactory answer you can go down and
say well what would be perpetuating a
stereotype if it's someone who's not
arguing in good faith uh they lie and
they say oh I don't know it was someone
else right they appeal to Authority
maybe they use the appeal to Authority
fallacy the unpopular fallacy well most
of people other organizations so asking
them using the Socratic method gives you
the opportunity to ensure that you
understand and they understand whether
you are arguing in good faith and then
if they aren't that's where you keep it
on that point why because this is what
would happen if Elon Musk just answered
it he would move on to another attack he
would move on to racism he would move on
to transphobia so Elon Musk knew you
know what this isn't going to be
productive no matter what so I'm going
to call out the first red herring here
yeah and then you stick on it you cannot
have a productive conversation with
someone who is perfectly fine lying and
another example of this that I wanted to
point to is Andrew Breitbart did this
when he was interviewed yeah and I don't
remember at what point this was where he
was being interviewed the same thing
happened when the Anthony Weiner Scandal
took place but the man rather than
asking about the relevant story decides
to ask Andrew Breitbart about his
relationship with alcohol and look what
Andrew does right away you can see the
moment on his face where he goes
oh I know how this is going to go and he
doesn't let it go
what's your current relationship with
alcohol
why do you ask just because you talked
about it quite a bit in your book
in what what regards the correct method
right can you be more
specifically I think it's fair to to
draw the fact the draw from what you
wrote in your book that you had an
alcohol problem that Tulane
misrepresentation I didn't have an
alcohol problem I had a great time in
college and I recommended anybody that
go to New Orleans have the time of their
lives
Woodbridge Virginia I mean I I I
graduated 20 years ago and I'm I'm
admitting to my flaws the way that
Barack Obama admitted that he did
cocaine when he was in college would you
ask Barack Obama in an interview with
him would it be one of the 10 questions
you ask him what's your current
relationship with cocaine well it's just
you talked about it quite a bit that's
where it came from so here's the beauty
he asked him why Socratic method then
said can you give specifics knowing that
he absolutely could not give specifics
yeah then he explained himself and then
here's what he did he took something
that was hearsay right he took a red
herring and then he instead countered it
with the truth it's irrefutable that
Barack Obama did cocaine and then he
puts that on the media as far as I would
hope you would ask him that or he knows
very well he wouldn't and that he has
not that man very likely interviewed
Barack Obama so what you do is Socratic
method you allow them to answer for
their claims you ask for specifics and
then rather than just getting into
minutia right you drill them on that and
then you you understand well we're not
going to go anywhere productive so let's
go somewhere productive based on truth
Barack Obama Obama was someone who did
cocaine with by the way a convicted
domestic terrorist Bill Ayers so that is
the way that you handle it watch these
watch these kinds of interviews look for
similar interviews and take notes it
really is a master class the best advice
you've been dealing with automation for
years well chap GP Rickles how have we
been dealing with automation for you you
walk in a room and everyone else
automatically walks out okay you know
what that's not very funny we don't have
writers on staff who can toss our name
on there okay well we don't have writers
here chat GP Rickles you should you
walked right into that one dumb dumb
come on man
shut up Gerald you're glorified blow up
doll I wish you a bottle of wine so I
could throw you in a Cellar for 50 years
jeez that's then you would assume room
temperature that's almost a death threat
all right I don't know what he's talking
about there was that Calvin over there
yeah with that shorthand beer you look
like a 1960s GI Joe huh well thanks I
guess I mean it's not about I want to
strip a firecracker and watch you go
boom wow what that's rough Callie you
played a gym teacher on TV yeah you know
what they say those who can't do teach
and those who can't teach teach Jim okay
and those who can't play gym teachers on
TV are that's pretty right and
you push the spin-off series because of
the short shorts all right
I was about to say something the chat
GPT I don't know why we didn't uninstall
that's amazing Brian I am sorry I'm
sorry what I was trying to make before
he got that insulting I don't know we
paid for it okay I know but the point is
that if you if you're giving anybody
who's a public figure who's about to be
a public figure in Hollywood or anywhere
else advice is the Press is not your
friend right and should always take an
antagonistic position always because the
only thing that sells is for them to
figure out what your Achilles heel is
and expose it that goes for liberals or
conservatives it doesn't matter
especially conservatives but if you
think the Press is your friend the the
same machine that brings you to the top
of the mountain will will send you
crashing down no it's just the nature of
the Beast yeah and it's it's pressing on
something that doesn't exist right pay
your fair share right okay just Define
your fair share I don't know Define your
fair share because I have to understand
you just stay on that point because if
he had answered the question uh in any
other way like here's what we're doing
to fight it or uh whatever it would have
been CEO of Twitter declines to comment
on how they will change the racist
algorithms or the sexist posts you can't
go along with a false premise you cannot
have a conversation because like you
said they will say refuses to address
sexism when he didn't Define what it was
and then when it was put on him was uh
uh I don't know and this is why they
won't do it with of course this is why
uh former Vice President Joe Biden was
in his basement instead of campaign yeah
well that you can usually ignore the
noise if you're an actor or something
like that but I think it's getting to
the point where you can't ignore if you
let the Press take control of the
narrative completely without doing what
Elon Musk does right then then you're in
trouble that's what I worry about no I
think you're absolutely it's it's look
the only way that I know how to handle
this is you have certain a certain set
of kind of guidelines that you follow
Socratic method first there are people
who do want to have a conversation in
good faith it's even you know when I
when people come up and and they'll ask
for pictures they say they're a fan I
have a series of questions that I ask to
figure out really quickly if they're
trolling right and that's usually about
70 friendly and 30 percent who are not
yeah and I won't necessarily go through
what those questions are because I don't
want people to be able to try and cheat
the test do you want to suck my tongue
yes that's the first one yeah
white rice yes it thins the hurt well I
do it so they stick out their tongue
then I grab the pliers
you got me a girl sometimes I carry
around a cold telephone pole and go
yeah
you watch this pops Crowder when I was
really young going through this and
appearing on media
um I can only imagine that you must have
been you know kind of edge of your seat
sometimes when you knew it was an
adversarial interviews all the time
everyone oh what about this uh that you
were uh one time they tried to say I was
the devoses the van andel's grandson
when I got punched in the face of the
Lansing Union rally you wish they said
well why were you there uh why were you
there you know as the devos's grandson
or Van Andel sorry selling soap that was
one of their questions selling soap and
I said selling soap they said yeah
because I said no no what happened was
they said oh he's the DeVos his grandson
I said yeah sure I'm a soap salesman
whatever and removed myself they turned
that into you were going saying they
were filthy homeless people union
members and wanted to wash them with
soap and I said well hold on a second
what about the guy who committed assault
and they never ran the interview huh
yeah so yeah this is what happens all
the time if you let them lead you down a
path with that kind of questioning
you've already lost identify who can
have a conversation with start with a
Socratic method acid and if people do
not Define the terms don't waste your
time and make an example of them and I'm
really happy to see Elon Musk doing it
hey hit the like button right now if you
are on YouTube or on Rumble you can hit
the rumble smash button whatever the and
get the hell off YouTube yeah get off
right now we want to see that number go
down to zero and you sell the son of a
gun yes yes I'm trying to take away I
didn't I'm not a big fan I'm not a big
fan of the shampoo but surprise yeah
soap is the same thing guys you know
what I mean it's not it's not did you
know that modern soap most modern soap
is actually what used to be laundry
detergent it's not real soap is that
true it's absolutely true like dial and
lever 2000 Old sobies they have like
three ingredients lye Tallow and some
kind of I don't know something else sure
but now there's a bunch of chemicals in
there and it's what they used to use on
the washboard so Brian you are
destroying your moisture Skin Barrier oh
man wow I smell like peaches at least I
smell like a peach you do that's all
that matters yeah I don't know why you
went with that scent I would have gone
with like tobacco and whiskey you know
what smell tongue let's see
sorry guys somebody pulled that clip
that's a big tongue by the way somebody
sucking his tongue in the airplane and
face off oh no come on
it's in face off it is it's when he's
he's on the plane all right we've gotten
off the rail speaking of
it's always fun having my dad here for
this never in his Wildest Dreams did pop
Crowder think his son would make a
living this way censoring yourself talk
about the Dalai Lama such disgrace and
we're going to talk about Gavin Newsom
well it's your fault you told me like
yeah that guy's an but I was
very young I sent you the article the
minute it hit me yes that's true this is
given to us by pop Crowder but here's
the it's a by the way one more it's next
week is the last free week of of Mud
Club lotto'scredit.com until the 20th
and we may have something major
Happening Here in the last week I will
let you know but uh I know that a lot of
you are waiting to end the free month
but it's the only way we can bring on
people like Nick like Cowan other folks
as if you guys join up we appreciate the
support let's get to Gavin Newsom
governor of your state yes Nothing Like
Us nothing like a lifetime of bad
decisions Brian I'll tell you what I
know you still have to be there because
of work and such but eventually you got
to get out of there and the sun listen
I'm coveting Texas if I said I wasn't
looking at property I'd be lying you
know what I'm saying tease teaser it's
actually my state too I know I got out
at one I just want to carry I want to be
able to carry and I want Bandoleros yes
Bandoleros oh sorry about my I speak
Spanish yeah I know it's Spanish for
Bandoleros but I've always wanted to
wear Bandoleros yeah under my shirt
under your I like the feeling of cold
that almost cold defeats the purpose at
that point you should just have a nice
you know hip concealed care under the
waistband holster but you're a twisted
person yes well I'd wear a leg holster I
want I want something I want us I want a
small yeah that's a Walter that would
fit well my calves are pretty big guys
all right there we go sorry we all get
can we talk about the hellscape let's
talk about the healthcare California
have a Newsome speaking of well Gavin
Newsom isn't really a big cats he's more
like one of those you ever see those
stick bugs yeah yeah with a good head of
hair though great head of hair great
hair wow okay so and six foot four is he
actually I don't care I'm producing
estrogen as well so Governor Gavin
Newsom and I use that term loosely he
has now spent the last couple of weeks
and if you haven't heard of this you
really need to know about it because
this is a push right it's sort of an
extension of beta O'Rourke where they're
trying to make a push into red States
the good news is it backfires in a lot
of ways and we'll go through we'll go
through how it backfires but more
importantly how you can assist with the
backfiring for example Texas they said
was going to become more and more purple
and then you have the irony that the uh
Latino uh vote here in Texas and of
course in Florida has become more and
more conservative because of how far the
left has reached so they are now going
on a red state tour specifically Gavin
Newsom largely the messaging is
targeting uh and you can disagree with
me you can comment below my inference
white so here he is making his
case whining about Republicans keep in
mind yes he is from the hell hole that
is California there's something deep and
serious that's happening across this
country all the progress the last half
century has been rolled back in these
states in real time in just the last few
years I don't think people fully
understand the rights regression
individual liberties on civil rights on
voting rights on the gerrymandering
that's happening out here on just this
African-American or the assault on the
gay lesbian bisexual and trans Community
the number one issue of the day it seems
to be getting rid of the word latinx in
Arkansas and number two getting rid of
drag shows wait so Han keep playing
serious moment in American history he
just said the thing that they're doing
getting rid of the term latinx less than
two percent of Latin Americans want the
term latinx getting rid of drag shows
this is a serious moment in American
history you mispronounced silly you
mispronounced Goofy and dumb you
mispronounced as out of touch as humanly
possible think about
[Music]
weeks
um you know more than your state less
than your state I should say good it's a
serious time latinx okay we can continue
but it's just fun just think of that
yeah this is how out of touch they're
getting rid of latinx they want to get
rid of drag shows can you believe it for
crying out loud like you're like your
your Schindler freeing the juice all
right let's go keep playing and yet
we're so consumed respectfully by the
spectacles
in Washington that I as an American feel
compelled as a governor oh boy to call
that out
in a more systemic way hey how about you
feel compelled as a governor
to governor how about that
tell him Stephen your city is covered
with piles of human and needles and
you have a record violent crime you're
concerned about a term like Latin X that
none of your voting constituency
constituency even want go and call
someone go and call someone who's
actually like you know a relatively new
immigrant here who's Hispanic go and
call them latinx and if you aren't uh
basically uh the the reason for them
being the new recipient of a teardrop
tattoo they're still going to kick your
ass they did the assault on the
African-American Community how hard it
is to get uh just to pay rent in
California or just to buy a house right
I mean forget all and and Whole Foods
and all these other the tax Exodus from
from the tech Exes from from San
Francisco it's unbelievable it's so
difficult to make a living in California
unless you're a criminal right well if
you've seen Pacific Heights you can see
squatters boots for free yeah and the
squatters rights by the way so it's like
I'm not going to pay rent and they can't
kick you out because it's basically it's
been almost permanent at rent
forgiveness in California that might be
another segment we should do but if you
are a law-buying citizen who sort of
understands the agreement and actually
obeys the law where you say well okay I
guess I can't afford this I'm going to
have to leave guess what that does
people who have no intent to pay their
rent stay and property values go down
don't make it a racial thing white
do it too comment below if
you're from California and you
understand the difference between
California Texas Florida he's about to
discuss Florida which is hilarious to me
nothing like taking the fight to where
your weakest Gavin the tour stops in
Florida Alabama Arkansas Mississippi and
uh it came just days after he launched
his new pack
campaign for democracy right but just
don't say homeless
it's unhoused neighbor I hear it I will
discard it but the progress the radicals
the progress is is this founding in this
nation this guy's the regression this
guy's the the rollback yeah to Europe
Europe's failed policies that's what he
he's a he's he's the man right and he
wants to sell the man to everybody it's
a roll back the rim to lose did you guys
have roll back the rim to win in the
states or was that a Tim Hortons thing
could someone comment below every now
and then I have a reference that I
thought you were all raised with you
know Tim's no no I just heard Rim roll
back nope stop it I'm starting the
issues Eddie Ryan come sit on my lap for
a second
roll back the rim to win all right
anyway here he is he launched his new
Pac campaign for democracy because
that's a fun word for them to say let's
be direct we can't solve a problem
without first identifying it the problem
in our country problem identified
authoritarian leaders who are still bent
on gaining power and keeping it by
whatever means necessary that they're
directly attacking our freedoms in state
after State that's why I'm launching the
campaign for democracy we're going on
the road to take the fight to states
where freedom is most under attack oh
democracy by the way we're a
constitutional republic and I understand
you're trying to argue the semantics
there but okay so democracy so is there
a democratic vote on lockdowns
was there a democratic vote on vaccine
mandates for state employees I just want
to make sure that I understand your
definition of democracy because when I
think California I think freedom
hit the rumble button please I don't
know how much longer we're going to be
on YouTube smash the rumble button if
you're watching on Rumble this guy just
pisses me off absolutely like to Ragdoll
him figuratively yeah of course was
there also a vote for from his
constituents so that he can go out to
one of the most Posh restaurants a
three-star Michelin restaurant uh uh in
California Napa Valley during the
lockdown right a group of his friends
yes I know guys but at least laundry at
least when I take my child to a toy
store I have the option of gender
neutral toys well that's yeah well thank
God for that Brian but this guy is
priming for a presidential run yeah I
spoke to one of his business partners
many years ago in Napa over some line
and he's like they have been preparing
that guy from day one to run for
president that's it guess what guess
what not a chance you know why
because the second a woman steps in line
or God forbid a minority you are going
straight to the back no one gives a red
test if you're out of Central Casting
Kamala Harris finished dead last in her
own state in a Democratic primary and
she will get the right of way over you
absolutely that is gonna is the
car P like she has a dummy riding riding
passengers
shot what I really hope happens is that
there is the first trans candidate on
the Democratic party side please make
this happen oh please that beats Gavin
Newsom yeah okay never let Michelle
Obama run every one of the states I I
think don't you think they're priming
Gavin Newsom to run against Trump don't
you think that this is what's really
going on Good Luck 2020. Good Luck what
do you guys say there pop Crowder in
every state where he wants to he wants
to make a difference that's been a
democratic process to go red right
that's exactly what he said yes that's a
good point yeah I chose a Rhonda Santos
dummy yeah we need to we need to bring
back democracy like yeah we've all the
Cubans uh Cuban Americans who voted by a
margin like 70 something percent yeah we
all voted for that guy because you
remind us of the guys who we hated when
we left what was his name Jay Fidel take
your pick really we don't like you now
here's the thing in Florida Newsome talk
about tone death I know
you'd think he would try and argue
somehow that California is anyway here's
a clip he spent time attacking Ron
DeSantis for things like quote academic
authoritarianism again through anecdotal
stories because of course he doesn't
have empirical evidence I asked how are
your parents feeling about all this and
someone who was very timid one of the
last people to speak she raised her hand
she goes oh my parents love Ron DeSantis
but they want me to leave the school
because they can't believe this is
happening
and and she said it's the first time
they had to square that reality oh go
and suck Mitt Romney's tongue you asshat
I'll take things that were staged or
never happened for a thousand Alex and
by the way nice job wearing a sticker of
a bear that you don't even have in your
state anymore everything about you is
fake everything about you is wrong I
don't like you and I could hurt you
figuratively now
who made you know I had just I've had a
rough couple of days so I'm just letting
it out I apologize you can comment below
if this is a little too much if it's a
little too much you know I give too much
money you need meditation I give too
much no he doesn't okay yeah I need to
detach myself just detach from caring
yes right that would be great in a
democrat in a democracy like yeah we
were going to vote but we were so
detached stare at your navel yes this is
this is uh we actually this is him being
concerned about his constituents in uh
in California here this picture out oh
that's the French Laundry during the
lockdown that looks like a sequel to the
menu wow good restaurant good restaurant
you've been there Gerald yeah it's only
about a thousand dollars a person oh my
God it's your house
I'm so tired of the foodie culture we'll
talk about it on mug Club but here's
news what nothing did you say Hayden
Heathen I thought you said Hayden like
penetier oh wow maybe married to
Klitschko that must be I don't even know
how it fits it's like next I'll buy
another gun Stephen and eat a hot dog
new democratically vote for another gun
Newsom uh also made some claims and
we'll go through the claims and the
truth just so you know that these are
all verifiably false because we'll get
these messages from you saying like he
said this but you know is it is it true
no it's not all references are available
in the description live with credit.com
we do all of that work so you can learn
and do a deep dive as much as you want
here he is making
incorrect or questionable claims at best
about red States yeah I'm in a state
that's 28 higher uh murder rate than the
state of California
state of Florida
I mean you can't make this stuff up
eight of them murder States in terms of
increase in murder rates are all red
states by the way seven of the top ten
dependent states of those same states
with lower life expectancy higher infant
mortality maternal mortality some of the
worst Health outcomes in the country how
the dev I mean look at their GDP rates
60 plus percent of the GDP in this
country or in blue States how are we
losing these debates yeah how are we
losing these debates how are those blue
States losing all of those companies and
this is what happens when Bernie Sanders
tries to say that Denmark is socialist
and the Prime Minister says stop saying
that he's like we're not that when you
build your economy for example you build
your economy on free enterprise and
businesses go there there's a delayed
effect and we are seeing them leaving
now so it's important to look at the
trend sure California is one of the
biggest states California had the
largest influx at one point California
and New York are the only states that
have had some kind of shrinkage or
complete stagnation Texas growing
Florida growing the trend line actually
matters so let's go through some claims
and then truth the claim that he makes
theirs at Florida has a 28 higher murder
rate that's not true the truth is that
Florida has a slightly higher murder
rate than California California is uh
5.6 per 100
000 uh Florida is 5.9 that's not 28
percent uh higher but um total murders
were much higher in California than in
Florida so it seems like so total
murders yeah in California where 2203
and in Florida it was you know 1200. and
uh violent crime rates were also higher
in California than Florida just
significantly yes significantly higher
so the violent crime rate in California
442 per 100 000 and then 383 for 100 000
and by the way this is assuming that
Democratic states actually register
their violent crime correctly which is
really hard for us to find a source
because they do catch and release uh
with no cash and you also have cities
that have declared violent crimes to no
longer be violent crimes right so this
is a very very conservative estimate
just to be clear living California is
dangerous it is I mean it's why I I
would love to live in a safer State just
so I don't have to keep up with my Kung
Fu yes so much do you know what I'm
saying I'll make sure you keep up with
it Bryce but the problem I guess here is
that if they don't kill you it doesn't
count right right maiming you and and
making sure that you're in a coma for
six months it doesn't kind of right by
the way I just want to answer Gavin
newsom's questions
your ideas are so bad that even people
that want to support you don't right
that's why yeah yeah that's exactly
right so the murder rate is uh the
murder rate slightly higher in Florida
but here's something the two that what
they'll also do no it's okay you don't
even get a little trigger happy there to
a man
um they'll say oh the states with the
top here's kind of the issue is what you
have is what these blue a lot of blue
States think of New York right you kind
of have one major city and then there
aren't like in Texas you have Dallas you
have Houston you have Austin you have
San Antonio in New York the next closest
would be would it be Albany would it be
a certain city by the way right exactly
so you have one really large city in
Illinois for example of course Illinois
Illinois is not going to have the same
it's not really fair to compare why
because Illinois has Chicago in corn
yeah
they're too depressed to get off the
couch in Texas you're still going to
have big cities yeah and by the way
that's relevant why because well okay
here's the claim that email X right that
eight of the top 10 murder states are
red States oh boy but what really
matters is not just the states but the
cities because you have a long standing
control over a city the truth is
democratic cities all of them have the
highest murder rates let me give you the
list of cities with the highest murder
rates Chicago Philadelphia New York
Houston Los Angeles and now Houston
would be in a red state by the way
Dallas is also a blue City Austin is a
blue City San Antonio is a blue City El
Paso of course is a blue area of the
state so we have a lot of other people
in the state and many many large cities
uh if you look at a lot of these other
states California might be a slight
exception also the highest murder rates
just to be clear number one New Orleans
number two St Louis number three
Baltimore number four Detroit there we
are number five Memphis wow don't
celebrate that oh I'm sorry I saw we
weren't in playoff contention here's the
thing some of those some of those cities
and this is why it's important some of
those cities are in red states that true
every single City I just listed is far
left every single one some of the most
of them are in blue States but some of
them are in red States every single City
that I just gave you and I just gave you
the numbers as far as the highest number
of total murders and the highest murder
rates you have to look at the through
line I've talked about this with mass
shootings you can always make the
prediction that if the shooter is
stopped they are stopped by someone with
a gun themselves a cop or held at
gunpoint that is the 100 constant
statistically the 100 constant here is
every single city is a leftist city run
by a leftist and all of those cities are
the perfect test tube
because they are unopposed Democrats
unopposed is the key word there's no
chance that they hear an opposing
political worldview exactly is a
democratic super majority it just is
yeah that's because of those big giant
cities which again are very dangerous
you move out of there and California you
still have enough population Temecula
you know you have areas like Bakersfield
Fresno but uh those places are plenty
safe yes just not in the middle and
those guys are so close oh God yo what's
a nap no no no what I'm saying is it
shouldn't be it's it's they should be
more left-leaning and they're not
they're all rightly look at Chicago
their new mayor I mean do you think
Beetlejuice was going to be followed up
by nothing don't change
you can keep it gun control well Detroit
rates are down because there's no one
left to kill yes when I was a kid it was
millions of people surprisingly gross
the point was murder went up yeah it's
like migrating birds
unbelievable migrating murderous Birds
the flying felony all right that's right
but there are lies damn like wait there
what is it lies damn lies and statistics
yeah you ever hear that expression yes
it's very important it's poignant yeah
Newsome to me without you try to be fair
but if you were to play if so if I we
were doing a sketch and the character
was looked like Gavin Newsom with those
veneers in that hair and he was using
his hands that symmetrically yeah you
would say that's a little much yes it's
a little sketchy a little on the nose on
the nose if it was a professional
wrestling character they'd be like you
know what the best characters just you
turned up to a 10 No One's Gonna buy
this that's exactly right it's like
veneers are caps Brian your thoughts I
think I'd have to taste his tongue well
because they keep get in line I know I
guarantee as a sanitary tongue though
because those teeth are whoa whoa whoa
white yeah
how can his ex-wife
be Donald Trump Jr's fiancee how can
that how could that affect they share a
son yeah what was that relationship like
same here same here
she likes she likes thick hair I I have
to say I'd love to run my fingers
through Gavin's hair yeah so the next
claim I'm sorry I'm sorry
[Music]
is that the South has lower life
expectancy okay so here's the truth and
this actually requires some context uh
the CDC actually does report that life
expectancy is lower in the South but a
couple of things this is the first
generation that is going to have a
shorter life expectancy than the
generation previous than the generation
prior okay the South has often had lower
life expectancy
um regardless of politics largely
because of dietary yeah they fry ice
cream yes they fry ice cream
um and later let's be honest here the
life expectancy map that you look at
very closely follows the racial makeup
of the region now of course yes when
we're talking about African-Americans
obesity is a problem and they're all
they're also even if you're not obese
there's a higher unfortunately uh
genetic uh genetic proclivity toward
things like diabetes Sickle Cell it's
the same reason that Acadian Bloodlines
I found this out there are certain
genetic diseases that are hereditary uh
to Acadian Bloodlines yeah well French
Canadian then they became like Canadian
but Acadian is French Canadian they they
moved to you know they became the Cajuns
what do you suffer from a barrel chest
well except for the fact that my barrel
chest caved into my heart it's a sore
spot thanks for bringing all right well
you've got a jawline that goes on for
days it could carve a trophy well that's
the beard I hide it all right so I'm gay
I'm sorry life expectancy in the U.S by
the way by race this is important it
matters Asian 83 years Latino 77 years
old white 76 black 70. so asian life
expectancy Asian American life
expectancy is 13 about 13 12 point
something years longer than that of
African American because they meditate
yes because they meditate and it's the
Fountain of Youth is the tongue of the
white rice and here by the way we've
talked about it's the first generation
of a lower life expectancy than their
parents right so that's across the board
so we look at different demographics and
why that's the case and it's not just
because of South right it's because of
demographics then you also look at the
trend overall lower life expectancy
which is shocking that's startling it's
the first time on record but I wonder
why gen Z would have a shorter life
expectancy then I don't know the
greatest Generation or even baby boomers
it is okay to be fat we can all agree on
this yes no sometimes you just gotta put
your big girl pants on tuck your shirt
in who cares if your food is
promoting obesity is what it takes to
make other fat people feel hot
obviously I'm gonna do that we have no
that's not obviously beautiful through
at all time someone
fat like me
had a breath like me
sorry
thanks Gerald
one's a question answer this I want to
hear your comments when's the last time
you saw an 80 year old lizzo's size
asian life expectancy is 83. when's the
last time you saw someone 83 the size of
any of those women
why are you hating me because you're
dying
award exception acceptance can be cardio
yes it can be yes yes absolutely if you
can only see her pancreas it's always
like this
yes but look at that Gap look at that
Gap from Asians down to the to the black
community 13. yeah almost 14 years
that's a generation nearly in some parts
of the world that's a generation those
are they're having kids at 14. well but
Gavin Newsom wants you to not know
anything about the context and just
think oh it's because of their policies
the oppressive regimes down here you
guys can't even keep people alive and
it's like no the agents just chose to
settle in New York and San Francisco
that's not our by the way it also people
say oh culture is a dog whistle okay I'd
love to hear comments from you but by
the way hit the like button whatever it
is share the show if you can but comment
below if you are Asian okay or if you're
black uh but the idea because if people
are Asian I've had plenty I went to a
school that was like almost 30 something
percent Asian yeah the culture and I
would be around I remember being around
my friend deaf kid guys named Kevin he
was he was definitely couldn't hear and
he was Asian he already had an accent so
imagine like a wow a really severe
Chinese accent he was deaf and nobody
wanted to be his friend and I tried
really hard but I remember his parents
telling his sister like you'll get a
chubby you gotta no you can't have
popsicle you're getting too chubby go
outside go play outside right they will
tell you in Asian culture they will tell
you if you are getting getting
overweight it is the culture of the
Asian family to point out and a lot of
the women value being traditional a lot
of women value you know still fitting in
a lot of women value fitting into their
wedding dress it's a generational thing
it was the culture of telling someone
hey you're getting overweight because
they know it came with health
complications now everything is
beautiful fat is beautiful okay also
General mutilation is beautiful all
right so is violent crime there should
be no consequences and then you wonder
you wonder why your life expectancy is
lower I'm sorry I cut you off Brian no
but I just think I think that the
narrative with the liberal establishment
and someone like Gavin Newsom is so
rudimentary the idea is if you are not
doing well it has nothing to do with the
actions you take as an individual it's
because you're either oppressed or it's
somebody else's fault and by the way
you're perfect just the way you are
right there's no work that requires just
the the essence of your human your human
uh form right no matter what it is is
perfect and anybody tells you otherwise
is racist misogynist homophobic Etc now
combine that with what we just talked
about combine that with the
inconsequential and by that I mean uh
soulless Eastern religions of the
concept of Nirvana or Enlightenment it's
all purse right Detachment I'm detached
from healthy eating I'm detached from
obeying the law I would say this about
the Asian so if you look at ethnic
Chinese in any culture whether it's in
West Africa Malaysia and they do not
they suffer from a lot of discrimination
they always Excel because there are
certain cultural traits like frugality
education practice and self-restriction
right so you know jamming piano keys in
your son's neck when he gets the wrong
truth that is correct yes and placing
the piano in front of the window so the
other children are you can watch the
children play through your tears yes
strength in this life happiness in the
next exactly but you'd have to say that
in your
Asian accent it's like happiness and
next little boy playing oh straight
hockey oh street hockey have orange ball
you love orange ball play now okay yes
papa yes papa
yes Mom they're friends now he told the
story his mom jammed piano keys in his
neck when he did it wrong and duct taped
soap in his mouth for talking back he
ran down the street and they called CPS
but now he can play the piano but the
thing that says mom didn't even know
what the problem was right they were
like did you uh Jam piano keys in his
neck and duct tape why are you here I'm
tiger mom she's embarrassed that he's
only a lawyer yes seriously she's
embarrassed not a naughty graduate from
SMU law school but he can make beautiful
music on that box we call it piano he
actually plays violin really well too
there you go nothing like perpetuating
the original stereotype but it's a good
point look everything about you is
beautiful no you're not you're not
you're not perfect and this is also a
problem in relationships if he loves you
he'll love you just the way
no no does any woman actually think that
you love everything about your man no
this stems by the way from feminism yes
it does it stems from third wave
feminism this is not to women out there
who are strong who work on themselves
but the problem is an entire generation
of young women here let me ask you this
okay let me I just had this question the
other day I don't know if I said this on
the show but fat Pride okay let's take
that here's the thing those people are
fat models those people are fat sex
symbols I've had women say yeah well
it's okay for a man to be fat I go
really
he said yeah yeah I can't go okay name
me one I go uh Chris Farley uh John
Belushi uh Jonah Hill I go yeah any of
them on the cover of Cosmo they have to
be wildly talented and they're
recognized for that there are no fat
male supermodels no there is no fat test
holiday male there is no male equivalent
to lizzo now there might be men who are
talented who happen to be fat but they
don't demand that you declare them to be
beautiful that's the problem is telling
you that everything about you is perfect
there's nothing wrong with saying you
are valuable in spite of your flaws in
spite of your sinful nature you still
have a lot of value there's something
wrong with saying everything about you
is of value now let me go back to
someone of no value Gavin Newsom on his
stupid red state tour which like you
might as well just call it my personal
failure tour you might as well just call
it like the contrast that I really
shouldn't be drawing attention to tour
this guy's an absolute
you might be asking why is he doing this
when his own state is falling apart
here's the thing
a lot of Californians are asking that
question too
over the weekend he stopped in Alabama
Mississippi and Arkansas thousands of
miles from the state he was elected to
run Steve movigno is a democratic
strategist and of course animal cross
secretary for governor Gray Davis a lot
of people are criticizing for leaving
the state and talking to a hundred
people in Arkansas six thousand people
sleeping on the street at night in
Sacramento alone
yep hey I don't know if you know this
you probably have heard about Budweiser
right you go like oh Budweiser they're
having a problem because you know I have
a problem because of red State okay well
on April 10th Whole Foods had to leave
San Francisco after one year because of
crime that was their flagship store
because people use it as a Dell as a
free soup kitchen yes that's what's
going on yes they walk in there and
start eating and there's nothing you can
do about it right as long as under
depending on the city 900 something
dollars one thousand dollars that's Prop
47 right so it's a misdemeanor and you
just get processed and get litter get
released right you just come back but
the security guards don't bother
stopping you it's too dangerous so
they're just like yeah what are you
gonna do yeah that's why in Louisville
when we were there they had the they had
the socks behind glass right and these
people aren't even eating low carbs so
they're getting fatter yes exactly and
that's the problem no you mean they're
getting beautifuller by the way right
untouched in those stores vegetables yes
it's all I can't find my cheese curls
yes neighbors are eating all my
cheesecake but we still have plenty of
liver yeah get out of here with that
liver and onions well you got hot Cheeto
keeps the pilagro generic brand
racist all right
so January 2023 oh oh no actually I
forgot this uh the San Francisco Fire
commissioner by the way was attacked by
a homeless man uh with a crowbar just to
give an idea as far as just San
Francisco here we have a clip there's no
sound you can start running it this is
the ex-san Francisco Fire commissioner
which you know used to be there was kind
of an Unwritten rule don't go after the
fight you know you you pull pull to the
side of the road when the fire truck's
going down this guy went a different
direction okay bye no and the state of
California went from a hundred billion
dollar Surplus to a 22 billion dollar
deficit well that's a rounding error the
tours uh the states that uh Newsome
toured Alabama record Surplus Arkansas
record Surplus Mississippi record
Surplus Florida you know record Surplus
wow yeah well California is losing that
tax windfall but it's just funny he's
telling them to say do it like us do it
like us with the crime and the uh the
deficit do it like us where people are
leaving in Mass numbers do it like us
they're going well I don't know we're
doing fine I don't know what you have
going on there we're pretty good here if
you go to Sacramento and you say to them
the homeless problem is a drug and
mental illness problem they will kick
you I'll lock you up it's it's a housing
issue it's an inequality issue right
that's what's really going on it's not
crime no poverty yeah it's not
homelessness it's
fat and beautiful I don't know I don't
even understand the Lexicon anymore they
open up their white man's fault yes they
open up their homes to help them they
let them in there Sam yeah that's the
other thing yeah yeah make some space in
that that spare guest room yeah well for
crying out I don't know if there's a
spirit guest room we saw those
they need to they need a junior suite to
themselves Sausalito Loft have a few
homeless in right that's it I saw
Pacific Heights
the San Francisco Chronicle also
reported that San Francisco has yeah
more drug users than high school
students what they have more drug users
than high school students by the way
also outnumbering high school students
piles of human in the streets just
to be clear luckily though
you can use here's the thing rather than
Sanford this is a good example a good
example of what he plans for the red
state tour right we need to bring back
latinx okay rather than saying hey
rather than saying hey that's a pile of
human
clean up this human guys okay just
a thought and then we should look
to human wow I'm surrounded by human
maybe we need to change the power
there's one and there's one and there's
human everywhere that would be what
most people would do instead San
Francisco California instead they rely
on an app where you can track the piles
of human yeah
yes that's a real thing yeah after they
eat Whole Foods they on the street
somebody's gonna flip that out for
hundreds of millions of dollars exactly
yeah yes yes oh gosh okay I don't know
was there anything else sir
that's right I forgot population loss
500 000 residents right between uh
between Los Angeles and uh largely San
Francisco Los Angeles uh not San Diego
as much but but between the years 2020
to 2022. they lost 500 000 residents
again the trend line matters you know
Rome fell at one point in time the
Ottomans fell at one point in time right
you can look at any Empire that's ever
existed and if you J at the tail end
saying yeah but look how big we are yeah
okay right now it's very clear the trend
line in California is bad on everything
what do I mean by that it's bad as far
as crime it's bad economically we've
gone from a surplus to a deficit it's
bad as far as population loss it's bad
as far as markers of Education it's bad
as far as life expectancy there is
nothing there is nothing going on in
California right now compared to
California 20 years ago three that is
better there is and this is a question
too that we always ask because I I want
you to leave these shows with some kind
of Solutions
so on a policy level sure I can say this
but on a personal level if you find
yourself in a rut
and I mean this because California is in
a rut if you find yourself in a rut you
find yourself miserable you find
yourself waking up every day going oh I
gotta do let me ask you you clearly have
been making a rut is created typically
from uh habitual decisions right a rut
means something that is continuous it's
something that feels never ending that's
why you have to make different decisions
so if you find yourself at this place
like California it's worse in every
facet that you can measure objective
right things that can be Quantified if
you find yourself in a rut it's a very
simple question to ask yourself have the
habitual decisions that you have been
making which have led have any of them
made your life better second question
will any of them prove to make your life
better the answer is undoubtedly no you
need to do it differently California
sweetheart you need to get your
together and off the street and do it
differently don't go to the rest of the
country to lecture them when they're
doing it absolutely right this is what
uh what we're talking about with
California this is what the hell are you
doing here oh boy here we go fourth
chair duties I guess
feel about infanticide what what it's
weird I got a suggestion and left okay
that doesn't seem like yeah
you're so old that carbon data
pretentious why do we have chat I don't
know this is
okay I'm done with you boring goofball
that's mean all right back to you dumb
dumb I saw you in the Joker for about
six seconds okay I hope you enjoyed the
high Watermark kid it's all downhill
from here I got cut out it was the best
six seconds of the movie for me thank
you I got a snack this is nuts something
you should pay for in the App Store tell
everyone the name of the character you
play yeah Brian what was it I was I
played a stretcher yeah haha stripper
okay no Buffy Irish yeah that's
surprised you're in the martial arts huh
yeah yeah I do see you like Marshall
let's face that's your best shot yeah
I'll take my no Brian don't Brian I
don't think it's worth it
I'm a computer you dum-dum all right
look can we just can we uninstall unplug
something right now please oh nice try
Gerald better comebacks for my
grandson's speaking spell that's pretty
funny why don't you go accidentally take
more steroids and stop bothering
everybody you take steroids no meanwhile
yourself Dumbo but just come on all
right that's dark man that's very dark
how's your Milkman have you seen how
high this kid jumps what does that mean
what is he talking about he says what he
has such a stutter this clown could run
for president how are you with sniffing
kids that's that's actually right yeah
yeah did you like that you like that
when I make fun of your friends I was
just laughing earlier with the president
sniffing kids line yeah you know what
else is funny you're patchy beard what
are you hiding your chin because you
think it's where you keep all your
talent you could have worked with a soul
patch it's not bad hey hey chat uh GP T
Rickles uh that's enough okay that this
is getting a little crazy
that's nice I guess he asked you with
his fire buddies not around tell you
what Brian why don't you try fighting
for your right to be funny oh come on he
is really not that's come on Brian's a
funny guy legit he sexually assaulted
you yet oh come on man that's that's
that joke blow that's ridiculous
all right what's wrong with him no
there's a lot there's something wrong
with you I don't even know why we have
chat GP Rickles on the this is what
happened with chat GPT and it takes over
the AI is absolutely taking over I don't
know what are you doing there to a man
Tim is your tricaster going to chat GP
Rickles take over your checks
so everything about California is bad
it's wrong and by the way we are about
to go to uh uh of course my club it's
free this month so if you're watching on
YouTube go to rumble uh and of course
you can subscribe.com There You Go slash
mug Club if you want to watch the Friday
show Brian counting you can go to
briancallen.com you can go check out his
tour dates but we're going to be taking
uh your best you've actually issued some
submissions we've done some tests with
chat GPT and things that might surprise
you asking questions again regarding AI
it's the programming that's a problem
how biased and how far left chat GPT is
we're doing that segment because some of
the answers and questions it absolutely
could not be here on YouTube and we'll
be taking your submissions right now
head on over to rumble we have an
another fall half of the show YouTube
you can piss off
foreign
[Music]